bonjour françois bonjour gazinière
bonjour julie salué lui faudra même pas
où tu attends pas comme une entame
aujourd'hui à quelque chose de délicieux
et kamel aux noix ou pas voilà une bonne
idée ça je suis sûr que cette fois les
enfants et bruce a tu me fais goûter un
homme est bien sûr soit pris dans votre
quand même tu préfères ce au beurre
d'anchois ou sur la crème d'escargots
terreux va vraiment eu incorrigible
casimir je doute que les enfants veulent
manger de thé caramels au beurre
d'anchois et moi je doute même que tu
arrives en rendre un seul qu'est-ce que
ça alors vous bottez tous les deux mois
et coûte cher au monde complètement
borné tu veux rien comprendre d'ailleurs
si nous disons que nous avons des doutes
sur le succès de talent c'est pour ne
pas être méchant grain j'en ai assez que
vous goûtiez de plus que faire alors
vous n'avez qu'a décidé vous même de ce
que vous voulez que je vende à sa
casimir c'est très bien bravo tu
pourrais vendre des millefeuilles la des
mille feuilles non des éclairs au
chocolat one on est partout oui à j'ai
mal au coeur des meringues
des meringues ah oui des belles morales
toute blanche
vous croyez que les enfants aimeront
sarre amos a dû voir on n'a aucun et des
phoques bon bah alors je cours chercher
des moraines ils ont eu monsieur du snob
le président de la fête on a sûrement
dans sa réserve bon j'y vais d'accord à
papa
va-t-on
[Applaudissements]
voilà
enfin et bien casimir ça fait vraiment
plaisir de te voir vendre enfin de bons
gâteaux je dois dire que ça a l'air
familier bien moi j'ai des doutes à quel
propos qu'est ce qui ennuie je doute
d'arriver à apprendre ces gâteaux pour
gagner les 10 francs comme monsieur du
sne homme demande à bout mais c'est sain
beccu casimir dû vendre un front chacune
de tes meringuée aussi sera différent
oui mais j'ai un autre doute à à propos
de quoi je ne suis pas sûr de
reconnaître les pièces de 1 franc c'est
pourtant pas difficile quinzaine il
regarde bien
oui d'accord mais françois tu aimais
bien la laisser là comme ça je serai sûr
d'une femme trompée bobo berry si ça
peut te faire plaisir quasi me tiens
merci à françois oui qu'est ce que tu
veux encore j'ai encore un doute un bon
à propos de quoi je ne suis pas certain
de pouvoir compter jusqu'à 10 mais tu
sais très bien qu'on tue d'habitude et
qu'est ce que tu veux que je fasse eh
bien tu pourrais mettre un des pièces là
en ligne je remettrai les miennes à côté
comme ça chie mihara pas l'erreur à
bombay coûte casimir je veux bien mais
c'est vraiment parce que dieu fait
preuve de bonne volonté en allant
chercher les 'bric' d'accord non voyons
pis à l'a déjà une
deux trois quatre cinq six sept les 8 9
et 10 voilà c'est vrai je peux faire
pour toi parti très bien merci bon tout
à l'heure ouais
[Musique]
et voilà
[Applaudissements]
c'est un jeu complètement fou j'adore
les moringue bien poivrer tu ne vas pas
pouvoir les fondre mais je ne veux pas
les moindres je vais tout les manger
pour mon petit goûter ça va être
délicieux mais enfin casimir comme on
fera tout pour rendre à monsieur du snob
lady franck que tu dois lui donner mais
je les ai tu me pu me les a données déjà
quoi
on me qualifie ce stand à nous charmer
nous ne nous jetons simplement prêté les
dix pièces de 1 franc afin de t&d à
faire tes comptes et maintenant tu dois
de les vendre casimir du bois mais bon
il ya tout à l'heure tu doutait de ce
que je faisais 1 maintenant tu ne doute
de rien
julie julie oui pas qu'est ce qui à
casimir tu m'as l'air bien énervé est ce
que tu vois une glace oui quel parfum
nous en choix sans doute mais non je ne
veux pas une glace pour manger je veux
une classe dans laquelle on se regarde
toi mieux le temps de donner à mon avis
oui minute papillon
merci
voyant
sa part est ce que signifie cette
comédie saba je suis beau hein je suis
vraiment beau qu'une province bat
casimir tuer un monstre sympathique
est ce que tu crois comme suit doucement
et jaloux de ma beauté enfin franchement
kazimierz ça m'étonnerait alors il est
devenu fou complètement fou de qui dans
les pieds quasiment en soit il faut
faire quelque chose c'est terrible
monsieur douche noble est devenu fou il
me fait plus ce qu'il dit c'est ça
qu'ils ignoraient que là tu entendu il a
dit que j'étais l'est avant ce n'est que
ça mais mais françois c'est très grave
tu sais bien quand je suis bout comme
tous les casimir us il n'a jamais existé
un casimir us les laits erreur casimir
tu as oublié l'histoire de ton ancêtres
casimir est pas non je m'en souviens
très bien ma grand mère me racontait
quand j'étais tout petit comme ça à vrai
dire françois c'est plutôt une légende
on ne sait pas vraiment si casimir est à
exister
c'est aussi ce que ma grand-mère me
disait mais c'est une histoire que
j'aimais beaucoup
ouais c'est une très belle les cheveux
mais françois tu pourrais il a raconté
aux enfants à jour c'est une bonne idée
ça et pourquoi pas aujourd'hui oui mais
oui pour ça c'est une très bonne idée
j'appelle les enfants 1 et reste à dix
enfants au lion avec moi a raconté une
histoire dans les pubs raconter une
histoire formidable vous allez voir
c'est une histoire que je connaissais
déjà et danger qu'est ce que c'est
vraiment une
quasi meirieu pressé de d'écouter
l'histoire et alors eh bien je n'attends
plus que toi pour commencer l'histoire
de casimir est mais j'étais content pour
bien jouer le rôle de casimir est bon ce
ne sera pas facile parce qu'il était
très laid tandis que moi je suis beau
mais je veux bien essayer on leur givet
les émirs n'a été bien ça se passait il
ya environ 2 millions 300 mille quatre
cent treize ans maintenant 414 casimir
j'aimerais ne pas interrompu pour un
détail sans importance alors donc quoi
la donne qu coûte que gémir puisque
c'est comme ça moi je nous donne un os
non invasive ne t'en va pas bon voilà
l'état songe alors à au moins 10 400
crise puisque c'est 414 son sens
puisqu'il casimir c'est fini lui oui oui
j'écoute temps je peux commencer
d'accord bon alors cette année là
casimir est arrivé à un âge où ils
étaient signés russe se marier mais fait
exceptionnel dans l'histoire de casimir
us casimir ai été très long il devait
rassembler à monsieur du snob mais
qu'ils ignorent c'est pas très très
gentil ce que lui dire écoute casimir
qui a promis de jouer casimir est alors
concentre-toi ah bon d'accord donc
casimir est était très laid et aucune
des demoiselles kazemi russe ne voulait
de lui un jour casimir est parti dans la
montagne à la recherche d'un très gros
baobab lorsqu'il lui trouver il a bâti
avec sa hache est pas bien puis sans le
trop de larmes il sculpte à une
magnifique jeune fille qu'il retire de
son de vêtements de couleurs vives à son
cou il n'irait collier de à ses poignets
des bracelets de cuivre puis sur sa tête
il posa un coquillage magique plat et
blanc qui avait le pouvoir de donner la
vie alors la jeune fille sculptées dans
le bois de baobab se mit à vivre et
casimir elle lui dit tu seras ma belle
épouse que taper la case émirats et nous
irons vivre ensemble de l'autre côté de
l'île là où le soleil se lève à puis
casimir est en à sa jeune épouse à
travers la forêt à cette époque-là
n'irai pas encore d'enfant dans notre
île mais beaucoup d'espèces animales
l'habitait soudain ils rencontrèrent un
animal très gros très grand et très fort
quel animal était ce
un dragon 7 et 1 dragway le dragon
s'adressa kazimi réduit 10 10 mois des
immigrés que la une fort belle épouse
battons-nous pour elle et le vainqueur
l'emportera avec
casimir elle ne pouvait pas refuser il
était beaucoup plus petit beaucoup moins
fort que le dragon et surtout il voulait
pas passer pour l'arche au moment où le
combat allait s'engager au nom en dit la
voix de kazimira qui disait ne tombe pas
casimir est je suis un arbre sauvage et
puissants ne tombe pas mon casimir est à
l'instant même le dragon s'écroula par
terre en disant alors j'en reviens pas
casimir est vraiment tu es le plus
puissant
casimir est et casimir à reprirent leur
chemin et bientôt arriver en vue village
des tyrannosaures qui était vous savez
les plus féroces de tous les animaux de
l'île puis il partit à ce moment là
casimir a vite arrivé le chef des
tyrannosaures entouré de tous ses
serviteurs elle fut tellement ébloui
qu'elle nous a pas bougé et resta là
pétrifie chef tyrannosaure lui dit alors
qui es-tu je suis les pousses de casimir
est
bien avec moi dit le chef tyrannosaure
casimir oeufs et lait très pauvres
tandis que moi moi je suis très riche et
casimir a suivi le chef tyrannosaures et
quand casimir r20 il a cherché partout
partout jusque dans le village des
crânes other comme il passait près de la
maison du chef du ran azor celui-ci
l'interpella et lui dit battant casimir
et vatan puis tu râlais très pauvre son
épouse préfère rester avec moi
alors casimir et lui dit d'un gang lui
seulement de me rendre mon coquillages
des émirats je tape à fenêtre le
coquillage magique à l'instant même elle
se transforma en animant ce baobab qui
en poussant défonça le toit de la maison
du chef tyrannosaure
casimir est autre actrice tenons chez
lui mais le récit de ses exploits
étaient déjà connues de tous et une
grande fête fut organisée en son honneur
[Musique]